se la cenere noi siamo ancora qua per
questo gioco incredibile chiamato lotta
ma salve ma buongiorno senta lei la foto
si chiama battimani mary wars the press
sarà mica perchè c'è un fantasma nella
schiena sulla schiena non sarà mica per
quello ma va ma va
ma quando mai ragazzi perché mai dovrei
essere depresso
buongiorno l'attacco su facebook che poi
è venuto da dio senza ma
lei può evitare di fare l'anguilla
niente mi scusi ma e sono tutti con una
faccia così il suo gioco c'è nel senso
nessuno si lava la faccia la mattina non
ci viene le info non viene viene tutta
su aspetta che mi avvicino perché vieni
tutto e allora se non la vuoi lo dici
prima omicida e tua sorella
c'è questa ragazzine chiaramente che chi
chiama chris levine stato sta piangendo
quando ridere per nessuno quasi
innocente che piange gente che applaude
gente che ride tutto sento e non vedo
nessuno e mi posso averlo io il call
camera insomma se non giocando bene
posso prenderlo lo stesso si ricava il
muro
[Musica]
io zitto cioè sito potuto farlo casino
lo so che lo posso almeno o grazie posso
almeno esprimere il mio dissenso nei
confronti di persone che c'è alla fine
non ha fatto niente sto poverino quindi
non piange non terrorizza mosto port
christian 4 di canguro lasciatemelo
pelle per far meno
tenetelo fuori la sta facendo ecco che
io mi poi mi prendo male per questo
poveretto almeno un po di rispetto per
lui aperta porca vacca c'è stan cadavere
nella vasca vabbè dai la porta è chiusa
benissimo ecco questa non è per niente
una bella notizia ma poi per niente
questa non è per niente una bella ma
zero proprio
posso lavarmi le mani volete una fotina
niente fotina inizia ragazzi ma
veramente andate via
lui che devo andare non vedo niente
vuoto totalmente aiuto a meno male
pensavo fosse successa una cosa di
peggio però ok però vabbè che la madonna
mi sembra un'esagerazione se posso dire
la mia è noto che nessuno mi chiede la
mia però raga mi fate uscire di qua per
favore lo chiedo per cortesia sesto
posto che veramente troppo o abbiamo
l'accesso ad un'altra bellissima stanza
finalmente vedo che le cose sono
migliorate perché almeno qua è più
allegro posso guarda la tv e dispiace
chiedo è un'altra polaroid
c'è qualcosa sul divano c'è qualcosa sul
divano bene era il momento proprio che
volevo fare la conta che cosa è la frase
al milan
avevo voglia di fare con c'è il pelato
c'è il pelato tensione
credo che vi siano più studenti i
capelli per luce una cassetta o e anna
baker weathering look poi vediamo ci sta
cassetto posso sedermi sul divano mi
siedo
ma che vi sento che siete qua dentro e
da due ore che qualcuno parla qua dentro
che cosa devo guardare non fa un cazzo
ma devo accendere il ok
minchia un attimo cosa è successo mi se
mi sembra un po un esagerazione cambiare
addirittura a livello a io faccio
ok questa è la cassetta ok ok ok quindi
adesso vivo ma residenti monserchio
quando trovi la cassetta salve a lei il
pelato e venga qua dovevano ska venga
qui per l'amor di dio è niente non
riesco a ma mai affermato sfizio ma
possibile questo è tutto questo nella
cassetta ci pensate voi come chiacchio
già messi signor x mi scusi nobel a tono
fuori o perfetto ecco qua c'è una porta
aperta quella porta a rischio me
entrarci mente che la fretta poi una
chiudete senso in faccia niente non mi
ci fa andare neanche a ciò notizia salve
superficie impiccata nuovo vista posso
misco posso parlare niente se lo fanno
perche le scatole come se fossero dei
pilastri insormontabili proprio le
mettono
la smettiamo di fare i finti spaventi
qua era impiccata heristavi la mi hai
anche aiutato nel l'orecchio madonna che
quadro dottor ragazzi appena non si
vedeva questo sbaglio ci sarà uno spazio
prima adesso vedo un appello una forma
liquida nettissima madonna di bile
vorrei levati dalle palle si attiva e
venga venga allora la smetta di fare
avanti e cerca mourinho che c'è questa
era questa era la cassetta ho visto la
cassetta adesso mi riporta davvero prima
come quando a ok sono io quello sono
colori prima ok ok sto qua dentro ma poi
è tornato quello di prima che sta
guardando il video è sceso anche la però
non ce l'ha video non c'è il lettore non
c'è di mor non c'è più lettore di
videocassette il lettore vhs il
ducatista dolei messo il lettore o la
gente che si fotte i lettori
veramente io non la sopporto negli ora
non c'è sempre qualcuno che si porta le
videocassette la esco di qua è stato è
stato bello forse è arrivato il momento
di lasciare finalmente questa casa dopo
anni di buio eccolo niente apposta alexa
ho fatto fatto fatto s'è aperto
l'armadio bene a rho adesso sono io ma
adesso sono io che ho visto che c'è
qualcuno nell'armadio e ho finito di
guardare il video è mai io lo sapevo già
da prima e adesso che ovviamente
si sa bene c'è sempre lascia che io la
prenderei ma poi fai tu eccolo qua di
psicologi psycology lo ammetto
esattamente dove l'ha messo il tizio per
aprire l'armadio devo ammetterlo lì
quindi è quello giro corretto e berlino
nicchia raga salve non c'è niente due
ore poi non c'è niente ma scusa che
cazzo era
google e picchiato pungolo per questa è
bella
un'altra cassetto
porca [ __ ] porca non ho fatto in
tempo a leggere cosa c'è sulla cassetta
ma non era quello il problema quanto
pare picco pure questa shes lei è vicina
e l'ho vista faccio i cazzi della vicina
che mai vediamo un'altra cassettina che
mi mancava pareggi limen l'inferno
eccoci il pelato proprio lui bene non ho
mai visto sostanza così luminosa sono
emozionato pelato fa le scatole il
pelato viene fatto lo shampoo dal
demonio il pelato fissa dove c'era il
demonio ma non c'è il demonio tutto
allegro
io sono il pelato pro twist cosa
whatsapp è lei a rue pelato and cell
devo fare un giro strano per
raggiungerti ballet ci arrivo you are
the pelato yes ai che si daisy lewis of
the calvizie però però comunque io farei
un ordine da amazon di almeno 5 o 6 lahm
panino anche di più secondo meno abbiamo
rotto dall'inizio posso prendere una
cassetta e guardarla che ancora hanno
viste grazie la metto io qua è la metto
quale in premialità nell'orecchio satana
ancora in acciao bastardo sori e sony
popolo di prima e novecento non so se
poi riguardando tutto il video
in questo video da andrebbe è guardato
guardando le date in basso per mettere
in ordine cronologico le cose che si s
no no no no
mi scusi è solo indietro e anzi no
vengono che deve sparire se non la
trigger un gioco non va avanti purtroppo
sono invece volentieri andato però la
torcia la prendiamo c'è un cadavere è
suo
posso impacchettarla roba a non posso
ragazzi come si fa a posso passare di
qua io sono andato non curante del fatto
che satana fosse nell'altra stanza
forse stavolta posso entrare forse forse
forse cazzo di foto
[Musica]
questa musica e motional dovrebbe farmi
capire qualcosa che non ho capito forse
vi devo impiccare o qualcosa del genere
a verona a ok quindi depilatore ranger
mi è stato detto che non c'era nulla in
quella casa ok
quindi alla fine sono stato quando un
sacco di tempo sono sostanzialmente
questa è la trama questa e questo è
quello che è successo mi pare che fosse
agosto prima vorrei di una casa tutto
non mi ricordo sono stato parecchio
tempo in questa [ __ ] a casa con i
demoni nel soffitto nel pavimento nel
lucernaio basta
[Musica]
ap riciclarsi portone o grazie
la chiave del cassetto apro il cassetto
e ci trovo niente la scritta a era
prefetto psichiatrico si sta parlando
del
il fatto che vede cose sente cose che
non sai pazzo non sei pazzo le vedo
anch'io che è successo perché mi puntano
sto facendo niente io non posso mancando
a pisciare scusate lo dice e se io non
volessi stare qua caricamento ma cosa ma
cosa cosa ho capito niente per cortesia
cosa è finito
beh
alexander resch simply cover cristina
reset incolla emilia non ho fatto in
tempo a leggere anche emilia spiegatemi
un attimo perché non ho capito oppure
spiegatevi nei commenti signori perché
magari uno a livello di gioco era molto
impattanti a livello di trama anche ma
io sono più quello che intrattiene meno
quello che capisce ringrazio tutti voi
per aver seguito questa micro serie di
due episodi sui laptop è il creatore
tappa hanno fatto anche un altro gioco
che adesso inizieremo non vedo l'ora
vedere come ciò un sorriso al 2020
perfetto che spero mi sia piaciuto come
sempre ce lo metto io mi piace anche
alle risorse anche mio sono nella
scrizione c'è stata così bis chiede e
noi come sempre ci vediamo ad un provino
belle ragazze
[Musica]